Yves, ich merke immer wieder:
Ich finde Rituale etwas sehr Schönes.
Z.B. die Höhenfeuer am 1. August
in den Bergen
oder Schuljahresabschlussfeiern
bei Kindern.
Du hast es nicht so mit Ritualen?
Höhenfeuer sind das einzige Ritual,
das ich schön finde.
Viele Rituale sind für mich so etwas
wie kollektive Zwangshandlungen,
gesellschaftlich akzeptierte.
- Nein!
Vielleicht liegt es daran,
dass ich zu lange im Militär war
und die ganze RS gemacht habe.
Aber dieses durchritualisierte ...
Mit der katholischen Kirche
habe ich ohnehin Mühe.
Daher ist dieser Zauber ...
Es gibt in der katholischen Kirche
schon Rituale,
aber es gibt auch viele
heidnische Rituale.
Man darf es nicht gleich
als katholisch verbrämen.
Gerade Gemeinschaften haben immer
versucht, die metaphysischen Löcher,
die sich im Alltag öffnen,
irgendwie zu bewältigen.
Rituale sind eine historische,
kollektiv geronnene Form
einer symbolischen Handlung,
die man immer weitergegeben hat.
- Das ist doch sehr schön.
- Ich sehe das bei meiner Tochter.
Einschlafrituale sind z.B. typisch.
Man hat irgendwie Angst,
geht vom wachen in einen
bewusstlosen Zustand, den Schlaf.
Das macht Angst,
es ist ein Übergang.
Dort hilft ihr,
wenn wir ein Büchlein anschauen
und alles immer gleich machen.
Aber die Gefahr
oder Schattenseite davon ist,
dass eine Gedankenlosigkeit
um sich greift,
dass man sich im Ritual
wie in einem Mantra auflöst
und einfach mitmacht,
Mitläufer wird.
- Mitläufer ist schon wieder negativ.
- Man braucht das weniger.
Nur weil es das
seit 2'000 Jahren gibt,
mitzumachen,
ist für mich kein Grund.
Wenn man die symbolische Ebene
nicht teilen kann -
und in einer pluralen Gesellschaft
gibt es immer weniger
überlappenden Konsens, was
den Inhalt eines Rituals betrifft -,
fühlen sich die,
die das nicht nachvollziehen können,
nicht glauben,
gezwungen, mitzumachen.
Ich würde es umgekehrt sagen:
In einer pluralistischen Gesellschaft
ist es sogar sehr oft so,
dass Rituale eben verbinden können.
Gehen wir doch zurück
zum Sonntagsgottesdienst früher.
Die unterschiedlichsten Parteien
setzten sich auf eine Kirchenbank
und man hatte gemeinsame Rituale, die
gemeinschaftsstiftend sein konnten.
Gehen dann ein Hindu und ein Muslim
auch am Sonntag in die Kirche?
Das geht nicht.
Zwischen diesen Gruppierungen ...
Dann ringt man darum,
in der Schule kein hinduistisches
oder christliches Ritual zu machen,
kein Krippenspiel,
sondern eine neue Form
von Weihnachtsritual zu finden,
z.B. eher ein Jahresschlussritual.
Weil man verstanden hat,
dass es eine gemeinsame Ebene
einer symbolischen Kraft braucht,
mit der man
Gemeinschaft herstellen kann.
Das ist die Idee von Emile Durkheim.
Z.B. beim Sterben
geht es mir komplett anders.
Gerade der Versuch,
auf Rituale zu verzichten,
wirkt auf mich oft extrem hohl.
Es ist doch total entlastend,
wenn jemand ist gestorben,
zu wissen, wie es funktioniert,
wie der Ablauf ist.
Er ist seit 100 Jahren gleich.
Dann heisst es halt:
"Er ist in Gottes Hand",
was ich als Atheist
nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Man sagt heute oft, die Schwierigkeit
im Umgang mit dem Tod ist auch,
dass wir nicht wissen,
wie wir mit Toten umgehen sollen.
Wir haben uns angewöhnt,
dass möglichst schnell
der Bestatter kommt,
wenn jemand gestorben ist.
Er bringt den Sarg
und nimmt den Toten mit.
Früher gab es die Idee
des Aufbahrens, der Totenwache.
Du musst nicht zwingend glauben,
dass es eine Seele gibt,
die noch Zeit braucht,
um den Körper zu verlassen.
Du kannst es glauben,
musst aber nicht.
Yves, ich sage dir etwas:
Manchmal ist man an Orte eingeladen,
wo Menschen ein Ritual möchten,
aber nicht auf das Ritual der
Gesellschaft zurückgreifen möchten.
Z.B. weil sie sagen:
"Das ist mir zu christlich."
Also taufen sie ein Kind nicht mehr,
sondern sie machen
ein sog. Willkommensritual.
Dann wird irgendein
esoterischer Quatsch abgefeiert.
- Das finde ich extrem lächerlich.
- Ich das Andere genauso.
- Wie nanntest du es?
Metaphysische Löcher? - Ja.
Das, was einen sprachlos macht,
wo man irgendwas tun
oder sagen können möchte.
Das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Aber ich bin eher dafür,
gar nichts zu sagen.
Einfach nackt aushalten und leiden?
Es gibt neue, schöne Rituale,
die man gemeinsam finden kann.
- Nenn mir eines.
- Die besser passen.
Was hast du erwähnt,
ein Geburtsfest?
- Ein Willkommensfest.
- Das findest du esoterisch.
Aber je nachdem,
wie das gestaltet ist ...
Ja, klar,
es gibt auch schöne Beispiele.
... kann es viel besser passen
als etwas Abgegriffenes
aus der Tradition, das ...
Aber du kannst kein Ritual erfinden.
- Doch.
- Nein.
Du kannst beginnen, dir zu sagen,
es wäre vielleicht gut,
ein Ritual zu haben,
etwas auszuprobieren.
Dann steuern deine Tochter
und deine Frau ihren Teil dazu bei.
Langsam
kristallisiert sich etwas heraus.
Erst durch diese Geschichte
kann ein Ritual entstehen.
Am wirkmächtigsten
sind ganz alte Rituale.
- Nein. Nein!
- Doch. Doch!
Wenn so etwas entsteht,
gibt es einen Zeitpunkt,
an dem es sich
nicht mehr stimmig anfühlt.
Es fühlt sich fremd an,
das kann vorkommen.
Dann muss es möglich sein, zu sagen,
man wirft das über den Haufen,
passt es an, ändert es.
Dann kommt die Orthodoxie:
"Wir machen es immer genau gleich."
Das muss nicht so sein.
Das ist eine Unterstellung.
Ich liebe Rituale, was nicht heisst,
dass ich an Orthodoxie glaube
und denke,
Ritual dürfen sich nicht wandeln.
Der rote Faden der symbolischen Kraft
muss hineingewoben sein,
verständlich bleiben.
Die Tatsache, dass etwas
seit 200-400 Jahren gleich ist,
finde ich keinen Nachteil,
ich finde das sogar schön.
Rituale sind oft
etwas Gemeinschaftliches,
in der Geschichte usw.
Ich glaube, sie sind
eine Angstbewältigungsstrategie,
die zu einem gewissen Grad okay ist
und die gewisse Leute brauchen.
Ich sehe einfach
ein Gefahrenpotenzial
und sie haben für mich oft nicht die
Schönheit, die sie für dich haben.
Mich überzeugt auch Byung-Chul Han.
Dieser Philosoph hat ein Buch
über Rituale geschrieben.
Er sagt, Rituale seien Einhausungen.
Er vergleicht das Ritual
mit einem Haus.
Er sagt, in einer weiten Ebene
haben wir eine Höhle oder ein Haus,
die oder das uns Heimat
und Geborgenheit geben.
Das Ritual ist nichts anderes
als eine Einhausung,
eine Beheimatung in der Zeit.
- Das gefällt mir z.B. sehr.
- Das schafft Zäsuren.
Man hat Ostern, dann kommt Pfingsten,
dann das Schulabschlussritual,
Weihnachten ist ein Rituale,
das strukturiert die Zeit.
Aber die Zeit, die Gesellschaft
verändern sich, wir verändern uns.
Rituale sind oft
etwas Konservatives, Träges,
das uns auch zurückhält.
Das ist das Ambivalente: Sie stiften
Halt und Sicherheit, Geborgenheit,
sind aber gleichzeitig
extrem konservativ.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es stimmt,
dass Rituale immer konservativ sind.
Es gibt auch neue Rituale,
z.B. Halloween.
Du bist sicher eine, die findet:
"Wieso jetzt dieses Halloween?"
- Genau. Weisst du, wieso?
- Siehst du?
Ist doch völlig okay,
wenn die Leute das wollen.
- Dann sollen sie es tun.
- Was hast du gefeiert?
Am 1. November ging man
zu den Gräbern und dachte an den Tod.
Das ist Allerseelen,
der eigentliche Feiertag.
Jetzt rennt man mit Kürbis durch
die Gegend und will Süssigkeiten.
Ist doch mir egal, ist schon okay.
Ich habe nichts dagegen.
Doch, du hast etwas dagegen.
Ich finde es schade, dass der
eigentliche Brauch nicht mehr da ist.
Der eigentliche Brauch, der
dem Wesen des Menschen entspricht,
wie er schon immer war,
der christlich ist.
Memento mori, nichts christlich.
Z.B. einsehen,
dass wir sterblich sind.
Alain de Botton,
den du gern zitierst, sagt z.B.,
es brauche Religion für Atheisten.
Er sagt, aus der Religion
könne man genau solches lernen:
die Zeit strukturieren,
Rituale, Weisheitstraditionen usw.
Das geht doch auch anders.
Man kann sich im kleinen Kreis da-
rauf einigen, was für einen stimmt.
Nein, eben nicht. Das geht nicht.
Dann fühle ich mich peinlich berührt.
Wenn eine Familie sagt: "Für uns
stimmt es jetzt, wir heiraten so",
und ich im Kreis herumhopsen muss
und nicht weiss, wie das Ritual geht,
ist das kein Ritual mehr.
Die Idee eines Rituals ist:
Alle wissen, wie es läuft.
- Das gibt es eben nicht mehr,
Frau Bleisch. - Oh doch!
- Natürlich.
- "Alle wissen, wie es läuft."
Du weisst doch,
wie ein Räbenlichtumzug geht.
Wenn ich in den Bergen bin
und am 1. August Höhenfeuer sehe,
berührt mich das irgendwie.
- Es ist ästhetisch sehr schön.
- Ja.
- Als neuer Brauch nicht.
- Es wäre genauso schön.
Es ist völlig egal,
es sieht einfach super aus.
- Wir finden uns überhaupt nicht.
- Einreihen in die Geschichte ...
- Findest du Demut nicht wichtig?
- Es kommt darauf, wovor.
Vor menschlichen Traditionen, die
irgendwann erfunden wurden, nicht.
Aber vor dem Weltall
finde ich es nachvollziehbarer.
Ich wäre manchmal auch froh -
z.B. in der Situation,
wenn jemand stirbt -,
dass man sich darauf einigen kann,
irgendetwas zu tun,
um die peinliche Situation
zu überbrücken.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Bedürfnis.
Zurück zum Einschlafritual:
Das wäre dann kein echtes Ritual.
Dass ich meiner Tochter
ein Büchlein vorlese
und die Tür etwas offen lasse -
ich weiss nicht,
wie du das symbolisch
überinterpretieren willst.
Ich glaube, der offene Spalt ...
... ist das Symbol dafür,
dass du noch irgendwo bist.
Ich glaube einfach,
der Mensch hat das Bedürfnis danach,
Einhausungen zu finden -
sowohl in der Zeit
als auch aufs ganze Leben gesehen.
Ihr habt gesehen: Rituale sagen
mir persönlich nicht wirklich viel.
Wie ist das bei euch? Braucht ihr
Rituale und wenn ja, wofür?
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
Wenn ihr nichts verpassen wollt,
abonniert unseren Kanal.